herzlich willkommen beim neuen video
ja und zwar ihr könnt euch
wahrscheinlich auch an das video von
gestern erinnern ich bin eher spontan
auf die idee gekommen in meine haare an
den seiten müssen wir wieder cool weil
ich wollte mir meine haare oben lang
wachsen dass sie wieder also schon ein
bisschen länger
dann werden die wahrscheinlich noch mal
blond gefärbt und dann passieren noch
mal was damit was ich noch nicht
erzählen kann aber das wird euch
bestimmt super gefallen da bin ich mir
todsicher und ich habe hier auf die
stelle ein friseur gefunden und zwar
michael der kann dass der verwalter
klappt problemlos schon jetzt wenn ich
also nicht als denn meine haut schnell
und einfach so ist dann einfach dort wo
ich bin
weil sie nicht fertig viel spaß
leute was geht ich habe brandt kurzen
location switch gemacht also wir haben
schon den nächsten tag auf jeden fall
bin ich jetzt zu hause und ich schlage
mich jetzt alleine weiterzumachen weil
vielleicht seht ihr das hier ist noch so
ein paar ja das passt halt noch nicht
irgendwie und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht er kommen
du nimmst es jetzt alleine in die hand
und wir machen das jetzt mal auf meine
professionelle weise erstmal
haarewaschen als sohn erst dann muss ich
mich ausziehen damit gleich die haare
nicht wieder komplett mein t shirt voll
mühe gegeben
ja so sind die haare nass jetzt muss das
irgendwie hinkriegen dass die sich hier
so abgeräumt oder ich bin ja ein richtig
kasse abtrennen okay leute ihr habt ihr
den rasierer was ich mir jetzt gar so
frage ich glaube dass es gerade auf drei
millimeter cruz jetzt auf 93 oder 95
machen
schön wenn irgendwas kaputt ist oder wie
wunderbar die erfindungen
ich bin diese weise geht voll klar dafür
ist irgendwie das sieht anders aus als
ob der seite aber das ist gar nicht mal
so einfach
wichtig ist ja auch mal dass man die
spitzen dann schneidet leute schreib
doch mal kurz in die kommentare
wie fandet ihr mich besser so mit
normalen haaren oder mit dreadlocks und
findet ihr blond besser oder nochmal das
interessiert mich mal weil genau das was
ihr besser findet mache ich nicht
gg
denn
ich würde eigentlich sagen ich bin
fertig kann mich einmal kurz im kreis
drehen
wählen sie die single könnt ihr bei in
die kommentare schreiben wie es findet
so im vergleich zu vorher ob es ein
krasser unterschied ist wenn die seiten
jetzt auch herausstechen und wenn ich
selber noch hand anlege hier oben was
die schweiz kommt an regeln ist auch
scheißegal ich hoffe das video durch ein
bisschen unterhalten wenn ja was genau
jetzt mal nach oben da würd mich
persönlich sehr freuen
und seid wirklich gespannt was da in
zukunft noch aus meiner herangeht auf
euch zukommen da kommt auf jeden fall
grasser shit den wahrscheinlich keiner
erwartet und ansonsten sehen wir uns
sonntag wieder um 14 uhr da kommt schon
das nächste video zeigt dann auf jeden
fall ein und wir sehen uns sonntag habe
ich mit der vorgang aber versprochen
sonntag 14 uhr